[Music]
gerard is kicking off this hour he's in
philadelphia pennsylvania gerard welcome
to the show
hey george how are you great how can i
help today
so
i graduated law school about five years
ago with 145 000 in student loans
i
got a car and a condo which i know
wasn't the best idea but um i ended up
last year selling the condo for a
50 000 profit and i paid down a lot of
that
debt
so up until about a month ago my debt
was student loan debt was still 106 000
i uh
i got a bonus at my job
of about
91 000 which was
more than my salary and uh
yeah
last week
i decided that
i was waiting around to see what would
happen with the pause and i i wrote a
check for
106 000
and paying off all my loans whoa that's
awesome good for you man and yeah yeah
thank you and you don't sound excited
let's oh yeah i i
paid down pretty much
all of my debt but it drained almost all
of my money and uh i just found out
today that they're extending that pause
again and
my friends are giving me a hard time and
i'm just kind of like your friends are
broke aren't they worried about
they are they are broke lawyers as well
yeah so let's not take opinions from
broke lawyers let's take opinions from
lawyers who have no payments in the
world
yeah and so i mean i i don't have that
much money left but i was just sort of
wondering where to go from here you're
about to have a whole lot of money
you have yeah what's your household
income
uh it's just me it's uh 80 80 000 of my
base salary okay so let's say 80 000
base and you have no more debt you still
have the car loan
no no that was the last of it so you
have zero debt
zero debt um and i i i moved back home
my parents are in florida and i decided
to stay at their house while they're
there and i did that was a huge
help and paying down my debt but i kind
of want to get out of my own but i now i
don't have that much money and i'm kind
of so how much money do you have to your
name in savings and your checking
account
uh savings and checking combined about
13 000.
and to you that's zero dollars you said
you have no money
uh no it's money but i mean
you know well to go from
you know 125 to the bank and 13 in a
week is kind of yeah but we've got to
look at you're 125 in the bank with 106
in debt you don't have 125 000 to your
name
that's true so when you look at your net
worth right what you own minus what you
owe
it's a very different picture
if i've got 200 000 in the bank but i
owe 2 million
i'm broke
right and so i want you to be encouraged
that you did the right thing it sounds
like you've got some remorse here some
regret
yeah i just think because they they just
announced today that they're pausing
those payments i don't care if they kick
it to 2028 man you did the right thing
by paying off your debt
there's no point in kicking the can down
the road even further because how much
was your student loan payments
when you add them up um
but when they when they restarted they
probably would have been
uh probably eight or nine hundred a
month okay so let's do some basic math
here 900 a month
times 12
means you can invest that money you can
save that money that's money back in
your pocket
from your hard work
not going to a lender
to make them rich so they can build
another building downtown
so i don't want you to have any any fomo
about how you pay it off your student
loan debt and your friends are going
dude you're an idiot they're gonna
you're gonna keep pausing it until three
years from now and they're going to
continue to be broke
they're going to continue to live on
payments i want to encourage you you're
going down the right path you make 80
grand you have 13 in the bank what is
three to six months of expenses for you
uh about eight
eight was about um about three months
that's five months okay so let's call it
10. let's call 13. you've got your
emergency fund in place
now let's begin investing 15
okay do you have any retirement options
i did put um i have a roth ira um that
my family told me to start before i
started making too much money
um and that has 23 in it and then i have
um a 401k that was just started and
asked for in it
great so let's invest
and this is the way i would do it match
beats roth beats traditional so do they
have a match in the 401k
uh no it's just a it's a flat
contribution regardless of what i
contribute okay so and that's already
busted and then i'm gonna move to the
roth options so do we have a roth 401k
or is it just traditional um
it's not it's just a traditional 401k
and then i have my own roth ira those
are my only two so if i'm in your shoes
i'm going to fully fund the roth ira for
the year with my paychecks once i'm done
with that i'm fully funded i'm going to
put the remaining 15 into my work
traditional 401k until i hit 15
okay
that's it
and if you do that and you're renting
right now
well i'm my parents are in florida and
i'm staying with that i'm staying here
in florida okay um
but i i would like to get my own place
because we're coming back soon
so beyond that we can start saving up
for a house down payment and i want you
to save 10 to 20 percent
15-year fixed-rate mortgage where the
payment is no more than a quarter of
your take-home pay if you do those
things you are going to have what we
call financial peace and you're going to
do it really quickly because you're not
paying a lender 900 a month that same
900 now becomes your down payment
savings you see where i'm going with
this
right
yeah i do
man i'm more excited than you are i'm
ready to get into this house man i'm
ready to do some things
you gotta stop listening to your
friends yeah he was just you know it was
just it was the biggest check i ever
wrote by about a factor of 10
so it's kind of
you know a lot more fomo like you said
well you didn't really have that money
because you owed it and debt is when you
owe anything to anyone for any reason
and so you had a facade that you had a
lot of money and i'm proud of you for
even saving up that much money that's
unfathomable to a lot of people
but i want you to be encouraged that
that money had a name it had the
lender's name on it from day one when
you signed those papers to take out 146
000 in student loan debt
you owed that money
right
well gerard i've gone as far as i can go
man
i don't know why you're bummed out i
mean america's cheering you on going
gerard way to go the whole crowd out
here and ramsay solutions lobby's
cheering you on you did the right thing
you just got to stop hanging out with
broke lawyers
your life will change drastically man
get plugged in with people following the
ramsey plan you're gonna realize
man i'm on the right path i'm doing the
right things for my financial future i'm
not doing things to impress anybody
anymore i'm doing what's right for
gerard and that is how you know you are
winning